ah here's a prediction for you guys so
about one year ago we went gdpr
Matt and what happened was suddenly we
had all these consultants these GV PR
consultants that were scaring everybody
going around saying you know you can't
have a CRM system or you got MailChimp
itself a little MailChimp spreadsheet
have yeah and you've got six people on
it o GD P R you need to pay me thousands
of pounds for consultancy lest you be
breaking the law scaring everybody with
all this legal stuff and guess what
turned out most roots was nonsense GDP
are the reason GDP up all those rules
out was to protect people from large
firms that were scraping hundreds of
thousands of data and then spamming
people against their will and that's
what GD P L came in not they didn't give
a rip about the little Michelle Michelle
Sanderson that lives in Wolverhampton
this has got 16 people on a CRM system
that's got a crafting business but these
big these little companies came out
mentoring people and teaching people how
to be compliant and on gdpr we went
crazy
we went compliance mad on gdpr and then
around about six months later it died
down and now everyone's living a normal
life again in business here's my
prediction same things happening right
now with the legalities and compliance
in property of course it's important of
course we need to be compliant of course
we all want to spam people we will need
to have the right insurance is
absolutely but what's happening is we're
beginning to go compliance mad and the
read people who are stirring it and the
people that are making this happen or
the consultants that are helping people
set up their compliant business and are
making money off the back of it off the
back of Joe Bloggs who's just trying to
package and sell his first deal we'll
try and and suddenly it's just we are
going insane and my prediction is that
in about six months
we'll just it will die down and people
be able to go back to their normal lives
making money again of course compliantly
but not being absolutely ridiculously
wrapped up in red tape to the point
where they can't move focus on making
money focus on the money making
activities do not spend six months
and 6,000 pounds becoming compliant and
then spending another 3,000 pounds to a
compliant mentor you have to do it come
on get real I'm so freakin mad about
this
[Music]
you
[Music]